les autorités ukrainiennes vont tenter
d'acheminer de la nourriture et des
médicaments à marioupol la ville est
sous les bombardements depuis douze
jours un siège dévastateur des centaines
de milliers d'habitants sont privés
d'eau d'électricité et de chauffage une
situation quasi désespérée selon msf
médecins sans frontières une mosquée
abritant plus de 80 civils a été
bombardée ce matin selon le ministre
ukrainien des affaires étrangères
armelle charrier merci d'être avec nous
pour le moment tout se passe comme si
vladimir poutine choisissent-elles
moment où il négociera les deux vont
négocier quand le moment le sera le plus
propice en fait simplement pour vladimir
poutine puisque c'est lui qui est à l'
attaque il a aussi différentes cartes
qui sont à jouer la carte de la
diplomatie l'a certainement amené ces
derniers jours à retenir un petit peu
les choses parce qu'il y avait la
rencontre à versailles il y avait les
ministres affaires étrangères qui se
retrouvaient en turquie ce que tout le
monde redoute maintenant c'est qu'après
qu'il a positionné ses pions une
première fois qu'on sait qu'il a
rencontré un petit peu des difficultés
il rentre dans une offensive plus
militaire est plus classique pour les
russes c'est à dire du coup de maître
plus de soldats de mettre des soldats
peut être plus aguerris on l'avait vu en
tchétchénie en 99 il y avait eu des
soldats plus aguerris quand 94 parce
qu'il ya eu une erreur en 94 et puis
aussi dans ces cas-là de sélectionner
les endroits où il va on a beaucoup
parlé david de marioupol parce qu'elle
allait stratégique c'est vraiment celle
qu'ils veulent il ya au nez sur un
encerclement classique où on étrangle la
population ou bombardent est ce que kiev
il y aura l'obligation pas forcément
c'est la capitale soit on va dans une
guerre très dures et donc dans ces cas
là on pourrait re les avoirs soient
effectivement il sentira que le moment
n'est pas propice et qu'il ya
suffisamment gagné ailleurs pour pouvoir
aller négocier avec ceux là ce qui fera
que celle à skier à ce moment là se
disent que lui aussi il est temps qui
passe la main à autre chose et les
civils pendant ce temps paient un lourd
tribut en compte désormais en tout
quatre millions et demi de déplacés oui
alors ça c'est toujours les ravages
d'une guerre c'est que on parle de
géopolitique et de politiques en haut
mais en bas c'est l'humain qui paye et
donc on attendait les chiffres en fait
des réfugiés parce que les chiffres
qu'on avait c'était les réfugiés à
l'extérieur des frontières
et souvent ce qui est parallèlement
c'est aussi les réfugiés à l'intérieur
donc aujourd'hui on a deux millions cinq
à l'extérieur 2 millions à l'intérieur
en clair qu'est ce que ça veut dire je
dit que quand vous quittez votre maison
si vous avez de l'argent avec vous si
vous êtes près d'une frontière si vous
avez un réseau familial vous pouvez
passer de l'autre côté d'une frontière
après ceux qui sont juste avec une ville
qui bombardé un village qui ont de la
famille ils prennent ce qu'ils peuvent
ils partent et c'est plus compliqué
presque à suivre parce qu'il n'ya pas
des de la même manière quand on pologne
effectivement elle a un million cinq de
réfugiés qui sont arrivés alors au début
le pays a été accueillants maintenant il
est inquiet parce qu'un million 5 c'est
très déroutant il faut organiser quand
est ce qu'on nourrit comment est ce
qu'on fait des soins qu'on ascona
chemine de l'eau on est dans des
conditions où il fait moins 10 il faut
aussi se rendre compte on est dans des
conditions où très vite la mafia
s'installe et où donc du coup on a
plusieurs retours d'associations
féministes qui nous disent effectivement
que il ya des proxénètes sur place et
qui demande aux femmes effectivement de
faire usage de leur corps pour récupérer
de l'argent on est avec une population
qui est fragile qui est démunie qui se
retrouve à devoir parer aux conséquences
immédiates de ce qui s'est passé ça ce
sont les situations qui sont
angoissantes alors on sait le gérer le
hcr le haut commissariat aux réfugiés
c'est le faire on l'a vu par exemple en
syrie quand il y avait des grands camps
en turquie mais ça reste des questions
qui sont fondamentales et qui sont très
difficiles merci beaucoup armelle
charrier pour votre analyse merci à vous